Speaker 1: Now, it is not only Jim Jordan
calling for the police to be defunded,
it has failed former President Donald Trump.
Yes, indeed. Yes, indeed. What am I talking
about? Well, I will show you. Donald Trump now in
the wake of his arrest, is calling for the federal
police to be defunded. He had the following
to say on his platform, Truth, social. Quote,
This is in all caps, by the way. Republicans in
Congress should defund the DOJ and FBI until they
come to their senses. The Democrats have totally
weaponized law enforcement in our country and are
viciously using this abuse of power to interfere
with our already under siege elections. Trump
doesn't like the fact that he was arrested, by
the way, not by federal prosecutors. And he is
now calling for Congress to pull funding from DOJ
and FBI. That is that. That's police. That's law
enforcement. That's federal law enforcement. And
of course, laws for the and not for me has always
been the Republican way. It's really important
to understand that when Trump says when he talks
about they should come to their senses, what he
means is I should be allowed to do whatever I want
with no consequence, but nobody else should. And
as I've told you before, there stated principles
mean nothing. Oh, we we support the police. No,
you don't. You support the police to the extent
that it's convenient. When it came to the police
officers, Capitol Police on January six, 2021,
all of a sudden they weren't the heroes. The
hero was Ashli Babbitt. All of a sudden now
it's not about fund the police, it's defund the
police. And remember that on Sunday, Jim Jordan
said the exact same thing to Maria BARTIROMO.
Legislation, write laws and pass legislation.
Speaker 4: So we'll look at that. And maybe most
importantly, Maria, is we control the power of the
purse and that's what we're going to.
Speaker 1: Have to look at
the appropriations process and.
Speaker 4: Limit funds going to some of.
Speaker 1: These agencies, particularly the ones
who are engaged in the most egregious behavior.
Speaker 2: So the DOJ and the FBI.
Speaker 4:
Yeah. And what I'd really like, frankly.
Speaker 1: Legislation the DOJ and the FBI,
it's not just one person anymore. These are the
folks who have been slamming the left for years,
saying, you all want to defund the police. And I
look around, I looked I looked under my phone and
maybe under my glass or why I can't find anybody
other than random voices on Twitter who want to
defund the police. No serious Democrats want to
defund the police. There's no serious movement to
defund the police. Do some of us want to reform,
restructure? Absolutely. Change training protocol,
100%. Demilitarize, of course. But there is
no big movement to defund the police except.
People like Jim Jordan and Donald Trump and all
of their acolytes and suck ups are now saying,
Oh, DOJ and FBI, we have to defund them. Oh, okay.
So when you say they want to defund the police,
you really mean you want to defund the police.
And what is interesting to see is that at least
for now, Republican voters don't seem to
be going for it. Let's take a look at that.